well there's been renewed sense of
opportunity amongst members of Scottish
labor at this year's Party Conference in
Edinburgh as the s p searches for a new
leader and Direction after the
resignation of Nicholas sturgeon labor
hopes to sell its Vision to voters well
joining me now is the shadow Scotland
secretary and Labor's only MP in
Scotland Ian Murray in Murray good
morning to you I do want to get on to
what Nicholas sturgeon's resignation
means for labor in a moment but first we
were just talking about a couple of
issues that will come up at the Munich
security conference one of which is
discussions on the sidelines we
understand that the Prime Minister Rishi
sunak will carry out with European
counterparts about trading arrangements
for Northern Ireland and revising the
brexit deal labor has said it will back
the government on a deal are there
circumstances where you would withdraw
support
uh well we'd have to see what's in the
deal we've always said that a deal in
Northern Ireland should be done and
kirstama was absolutely correct to say
to the Prime Minister that if he can't
get a deal that's in Northern Ireland's
interest and then the national interest
through Parliament because of his own
Ventures then we will give him labor
votes to get that through Parliament
it's the gay the grow up thing to do we
can't go on
um with the Prime Minister being so weak
with his own party that he can't get
anything through the national interest
to try and make this brexit process work
for Northern Ireland for the rest of the
UK so the offer is there
um if this is a case of the deal coming
back that is a good deal that we can
work with in Northern Ireland can work
with then let's get that through
Parliament let's work together to get it
through and try and put these kinds of
big issues that have been on the table
for too long now in Northern Ireland to
bed
well yes and do you have any red lines
then on this so-called Northern Ireland
protocol are you comfortable for example
with the European court of justice
having any level involvement in Northern
Ireland are there any issues around
sovereignty for you well the bottom Lane
for us is we need to see the deal
normally quite knows what's going to be
in it and we'll analyze that deal when
it comes but it seems to me that the
Prime Minister has a slightly different
attitude to his predecessors of trying
to get something across the line as a
25th anniversary in April of the Good
Friday agreement the president of the
United States has been pretty clear that
these issues need to be resolved before
that in order for us to be able to get
to a position where we can celebrate the
25th anniversary good friend agreement
that is not under undermined let's see
what's in the deal first but the offer
is there to the Prime Minister and I'll
repeat that again that if you can't get
a deal that's in Northern Ireland's
interest and then the national interest
through uh Parliament because of his own
back Ventures on brexit then he can have
Labor votes to get that through and we
will help the Prime Minister get this
over the line yeah it's interesting
you're making that promise before seeing
the deal though is this all about Labor
being Keen to be seen as a pro-brexit
party no matter what well no we've been
calling for a deal on the protocol now
for many months um in terms of trying to
get a Veterinary Group which would take
away quite a lot of the problems in
trade between goods East to West we've
been asking for a digital agreement and
I believe that New Zealand has just done
a similar deal with the European Union
so there are deals on the table that
could be done to ease the process and
the problems with the protocol and but
it's quite clear that the Prime Minister
has been too weak with his own party in
order to get any of these issues over
the line and is being forced to do so
now if he brings back a deal we will
back that deal enthusiastically we'll of
course have to see what's in it but
we're seeing quite clear to the Prime
Minister that if he wants to get a deal
over the line that's a good deal for
Northern Ireland and the rest of the
United Kingdom then he can have Labor
votes because what we don't want is for
this whole process it's a collapse that
would end up not being in the National
interest and not in Northern Ireland's
interest on the basis that he can't get
it through his own his own party
but you'll only back that deal
enthusiastically if you like it is what
you're saying well we'll have to see the
detail off it we can't speculate on what
it's going to see we don't even know if
you get a deal we're even speculating
that we might see something next week so
it's speculation upon speculation but I
just repeat again the offer to the Prime
Minister that if he needs votes if it is
a deal that's in the National interest
and good for Northern Ireland he can
have Labor votes in the House of Commons
to get this over the line
what does Nicholas sturgeon's
resignation mean for labor yours was the
only seat that labor won in Scotland at
the last election how many colleagues do
you expect to join you on the house of
common benches at the next election well
NASA was done a phenomenal job over the
last two years to get us to 30 and Below
30s in the opinion Paul's well opinion
pulls out yesterday that showed that we
would do rather well in terms of of
seats in his speech yesterday at
Scottish liver Party Conference was all
about policy all about renewing Scotland
and all about changing Scotland for the
better and I think there's an
opportunity now that Nicholas sturgeon
has resigned to reset Scottish politics
to get back talking to the Scottish
people about the priorities of ordinary
Scots which are the same priorities
across the whole of the United Kingdom
the NHS education the economy and jobs
and he set up yesterday a whole host of
new policy announcements to try and get
Scottish politics away from this
paralysis of the Constitution and back
onto the priorities of of Scots all over
the country and I think it was a really
good speech that I hope voters will look
at now and see that Scottish labels back
on the pitch and also the Scottish
voters could now vote for Scottish labor
to get more Scottish labor MPS and get
care style over the line to become the
next prime minister of the United
Kingdom what's your target what's the
ambition for labor in Scotland as some
have said that 25 seats in Scotland
would be possible what's your target
well we don't put numbers on these
things because what we want to do is
fight for every vote
um and what we've seen over the last two
years a complete transformation in both
the UK and Scottish labor parties and we
want to turn that transformation into a
very positive Progressive policy
platform which care storm has been
laying out over the last 18 months and
certainly an Assad was laying out more
of it yesterday and we want to put that
to the Scottish people and say look
here's a real opportunity now to give
Scotland the change that it needs this
will be a change election uh come the
next general election at UK level it's
time to put vote labor again put more
Scottish labor MPS onto the government
benches and transform the United Kingdom
and I changed Scotland but isn't the s p
always going to be the natural home for
anyone in Scotland who wants
independence why would someone who
believes in Scottish independence vote
for labor uh well this common cause
across many things in Scotland and the
priorities are to deal with the crisis
of our public services to grow the
economy to create jobs those are the big
priorities of the Scottish people and
those are our priorities those are what
we want to be talking about those are
the policies we were talking about
yesterday and we're in anas is wonderful
speech so those are the key things that
Scots are talking around the kitchen
table at the moment the cost of living
crisis the energy crisis Etc and we're
offering that policy platform that says
look we want to be in government we've
got an opportunity here to get rid of
this conservative government and s p
can't do that come and join us on that
Journey it contribute Scottish labor MPS
to the labor benches and government and
let's transform every part of the United
Kingdom from the government benches
other circumstances under which labor
would allow a second Scottish
independence referendum none whatsoever
okay we'll leave it there in Murray uh
thanks very much indeed for your time at
Shadow Scottish secretary we appreciate
it thank you